la séance s'est ouverte monsieur le
ministre je le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
que du bonheur d'être avec vous ce matin
pour la dernière séance de l'année 2022
je suis sûr qu'après vous prendrez
quelques jours de congés bien mérité
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée il
n'y a pas d'observation le procès-verbal
est adopté sous les réserves d'usage
chers collègues les conclusions adoptées
par la Conférence des Présidents réunis
hier soir sont consultables sur le site
du Sénat en l'absence d'observation je
considère ces conclusions comme adopter
la parole est à monsieur Éric Bocquet
pour un rappel au règlement merci
monsieur le Président yamic chers
collègues difficile à ce stade de ne pas
évoquer le déroulement de cette de ce
débat budgétaire dans ce PLF 2023 nous
sommes les pilogues en tout cas pour ce
qui concerne le Sénat de ce débat
budgétaire et après les élections de
juin 2022 certains imaginaient que dans
la nouvelle configuration politique de
l'Assemblée nationale le rôle du
Parlement de l'assemblée est donc
conséquemment du Sénat serait renforcé
nous humains au mois de septembre
dernier à l'annonce des fameux dialogues
de Bercy ah les dialogues de Bercy
c'était beau beau comme du Verlaine et
depuis le 19 octobre le gouvernement a
utilisé l'article 49-3 à 9 reprises et
s'apprête à le réutiliser dimanche
prochain selon les rumeurs qui courent
dans les couloirs ce sera la version
dominicale du 49-3 histoire de rappeler
à tout le monde que c'est bien vous qui
décidez nous considérons pour notre part
que cette séquence budgétaire aura
affaibli le pouvoir parlementaire
l'usage du 49-3 est constitutionnel
certes mais l'abus du 49.3 mine le
parlementarisme et aussi dans le même
temps la confiance de nos concitoyens le
président de la République déclaré au
soir du deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle je cite je sais que
nombre de nos compatriotes ont voté ce
jour pour moi non pour soutenir mes
idées que les idées que je porte mais
pour faire barrage à celle de l'extrême
droite fin de citation
n'oublions pas ces paroles et mesurons
bien les dangers politiques nourris par
le mépris du Parlement d'une part et les
doutes profonds qu'expriment
régulièrement nos compatriotes merci
merci chers collègues te donner de ce
rappel au règlement la parole est Madame
Vernet
pour une mise au point au sujet d'un
vote chers collègues
non
encore mieux que mieux la parole est au
président Jean-Claude Roquier pour une
mise au point au sujet d'un vote alors
le président lors des scrutins numéro 98
à 104 portant sur la proposition de loi
visant rétablir l'égalité territoriale
face au désert médicaux et à garantir
l'accès au saut et la santé pour tous
liée pour
et acte est donné de votre mise au point
elle sera publiée au Journal officiel et
figurant dans l'analyse politique du
scrutin
j'informe le Sénat que la commission
mixte paritaire chargée d'élaborer un
texte sur les dispositions restantes
discussions du projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2023 2027 n'est pas
parvenu à la notion d'un texte commun
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet de loi de finance considérée
comme adopter un nouvel lecture par
l'Assemblée nationale en application de
l'article 49.3 de la Constitution pour
2023 dans la discussion générale la
parole est à Monsieur Gabriel Attal
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs l'année qui
s'achève a été celle d'un choix d'une
constance absolue refusée que le choc
d'inflation ne mette au tapis l'économie
française depuis le 1er jour nous avons
affirmé une ligne extrêmement claire
celle du soutien et de la protection
protéger encore et protéger toujours
protéger les ménages protéger les
entreprises protéger nos collectivités
le projet de loi de finances que nous
examinons aujourd'hui en nouvelle
lecture tout comme la loi de finances
rectificative promulguée le 1er décembre
dernier resteront comme les textes des
engagements tenus vis-à-vis des Français
grâce aux mesures que nous avons
proposées la France est aujourd'hui le
pays d'Europe dans lequel les ménages
sont les moins exposés à la flambée des
prix se rempart contre la vie chère nous
avons pu l'ériger parce que nous avons
fait le choix collectivement d'un
soutien public franc et massif une
analyse de la direction générale du
Trésor publié la semaine dernière montre
que l'État a pris à sa charge plus de la
moitié du choc inflationniste et du floc
du choc énergétique que subit notre pays
depuis plus d'une année entre les
boucliers tarifaires que nous avons été
les premiers à mettre en œuvre en Europe
la ristourne sur les prix il y a la
pompe le chèque exceptionnel la
revalorisation des pensions de retraite
et des prestations sociales ce sont près
de 110 milliards d'euros d'argent public
qui ont été mis sur la table pour
protéger les Français et protéger notre
économie
ces mesures ont conduit l'État à assumer
52% de la perte de revenus réels liés au
choc énergétique laissant les
entreprises en assumer 42% et les
ménages
6%. 6% de reste à charge pour les
Français en des temps d'inflation c'est
évidemment trop je n'ignore rien des
difficultés de ces millions de ménages
qui vivent à l'Europe mais je vous le
dis mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
nous pouvons être fiers d'avoir fait le
choix en France de la protection nous
avons choisi de protéger le pouvoir
d'achat nous avons choisi de soutenir
les Français et nos entreprises nous
avons choisi de préserver au maximum
l'activité économique et la croissance
oui une fois encore nous avons fait le
choix de la protection c'est un choix de
justice mais c'est aussi un choix
d'efficacité cette stratégie est
efficace car il vaut mieux investir pour
préserver que payer pour réparer
comme durant la crise sanitaire notre
pays a ainsi évité une explosion de la
pauvreté qui frappe certains de nos
voisins européens cela était possible
grâce notamment à la revalorisation
anticipée des prestations sociales
délétées 2022 au financement d'une aide
exceptionnelle de rentrer de 100 euros
pour 11 millions de familles au
versement d'un chèque énergie
exceptionnelle à 12 millions de ménages
à la mise en place de dispositifs
spécifiques pour nos concitoyens qui se
chauffent au fioul ou qui se chauffent
au bois en parallèle notre politique en
faveur du travail et de la stabilité
fiscale continue de porter ses fruits
puisque le chômage se maintient à un
niveau historiquement bas de 7,3% tandis
que l'investissement des entreprises
résistent plus 2,8% acquis en 2022 il ne
s'agit pas à nouveau de dresser un
tableau qui consisterait à dire que tout
va bien dans le meilleur des mondes
évidemment il s'agit de dire que notre
économie résiste et que si elle résiste
c'est non pas grâce au gouvernement à la
majorité qui seul serait les garants de
cette capacité de résistance c'est grâce
au million de Français qui se lèvent le
matin pour aller travailler c'est grâce
au million d'entrepreneurs qui
continuent à investir à embaucher c'est
grâce aux Français qui continuent aussi
bien que possible à consommer aussi
parce que nous prenons des mesures pour
protéger leur pouvoir d'achat
le budget que nous présentons pour
l'année prochaine traduit la continuité
de cette stratégie sans jamais perdre de
vue que l'argent public c'est l'argent
des Français et que chaque euro investit
doit être un euro efficace nous
l'assumons ce projet de loi de finances
est un projet de loi de combat contre la
vie chère avec le maintien des boucliers
tarifaires avec l'indexation du barème
de l'impôt sur le revenu durant le débat
parlementaire le texte a été enrichi de
mesure très concrètes des mesures qui
pour moi ont un fil conducteur
extrêmement important celui de redonner
de l'oxygène à ces millions de Français
qui travaillent et qui peuvent parfois
avoir le sentiment que le soutien public
que l'argent public va davantage
accompagner certains de nos concitoyens
qui ne travaillent pas plutôt que eux
qui se lèvent le matin pour aller
travailler c'est extrêmement important
que nous nous adressions aussi à ces
Français qui travaillent qui se lèvent
le matin qui font des efforts dans des
contextes et dans des circonstances
parfois difficiles et que nous leur
montrions
que l'action publique que l'argent
public est aussi là pour eux c'est pour
les Français qui travaillent que nous
avons fait le choix d'indexer le barème
de l'impôt sur le revenu c'est 6
milliards d'euros qui auraient sinon été
prélevés sur ces Français qui
travaillent c'est pour les Français qui
travaillent que nous avons décidé de
relever le plafond et la valeur faciale
du ticket restaurant passant de 11,84 à
13 euros c'est pour les Français qui
travaillent que nous avons fait le choix
de rehausser de 50% le plafond du crédit
d'impôt garde d'enfant qui sera porté à
3500 euros c'est pour les Français qui
travaillent et nos entrepreneurs que
nous avons fait le choix de relever le
plafond permettant de bénéficier du taux
réduit d'impôt sur les sociétés pour les
PME c'est pour les Français qui
travaillent que nous avons fait le choix
de redonner de l'oxygène à nos
agriculteurs avec la prorogation jusqu'à
2025 de la déduction pour épargne de
précaution ainsi que son indexation à
l'inflation
ce projet de loi de finance c'est aussi
celui du réarmement de nos services
publics ce texte c'est plus de moyens
pour la police plus de moyens pour la
justice plus de moyens pour nos armées
dans un contexte géopolitique à haut
risque dans le cadre de la loi de
programmation militaire ce texte prévoit
une hausse de 3 milliards d'euros pour
la mission défense s'agissant des moyens
de nos forces de sécurité c'est un
milliard 400 millions d'euros de crédit
supplémentaires c'est plus de moyens
pour les équipements pour les
technologies numériques et plus de
moyens pour renforcer la présence des
policiers et des gendarmes sur la loi
publique la loi publique conformément à
la trajectoire de la loopmie que vous
avez adoptée enfin nous poursuivons le
renforcement des moyens du ministère de
la Justice avec une nouvelle hausse de
8% pour la troisième année consécutive
au global depuis 2017 c'est plus de 40%
de hausse pour les crédits du ministère
de la Justice nous agissons et je le
disais il y a un instant pour lutter
contre l'insécurité nous agissons aussi
pour lutter contre l'impunité pour faire
en sorte que notre justice puisse
fonctionner plus efficacement et plus
rapidement tout ceci est cohérent avec
le choix que nous faisons dans le cadre
de la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale puisque l'an prochain pour la
première fois dans l'histoire le budget
de l'hôpital public dépassera les 100
milliards d'euros sur le plan économique
notre principal objectif est de gagner
la bataille du plein emploi d'ici à 2027
c'est grâce au travail des Français que
la croissance résiste c'est par
l'augmentation du volume de travail que
nous serons en mesure de créer plus de
richesses et de les redistribuer le
plein emploi ça commence par l'éducation
l'année prochaine le budget de
l'Éducation nationale va augmenter de
près de 4 milliards d'euros comme le
président de la République s'y était
engagé pendant la campagne aucun
professeur ne débutera sa carrière en
dessous de 2000 euros net par mois
le plein emploi c'est aussi
l'apprentissage se sont ainsi similiars
700 millions d'euros de crédit
supplémentaires qui seront investis dans
l'emploi et dans l'apprentissage pour
atteindre le million d'apprentis d'ici à
2027 enfin je le dis avec fermeté ce
texte acte le refus catégorique du
laisser aller budgétaire comme ministre
des comptes publics je continuerai à
défendre le combien ça coûte parce que
l'argent public ne sera jamais de
l'argent magique oui malgré les aléas
nous poursuivons le rétablissement des
comptes amorcés dès 2021 en stabilisant
le sol de public à 5% cette année comme
en 2023 nous y parviendrons parce que
nous maîtrisons l'évolution des dépenses
nous y parviendrons aussi grâce aux
recettes liées à la contribution sur les
rentes infra marginales
lorsqu'on juillet nous évoquions notre
volonté de nous inscrire dans un cadre
européen certains ont cru y voir une
manœuvre dilatoire une façon de balayer
le problème d'un revers de la main la
réalité c'est que nous ferons entrer 11
milliards d'euros supplémentaires dans
les caisses de l'État l'année prochaine
grâce à cette contribution sur les rente
inframarginales des énergéticiens elles
permettront ils permettront de financer
nos mesures en faveur des menaces des
entreprises et des collectivités locales
ces grands objectifs nous avons eu
l'occasion d'en discuter de façon
approfondie le débat également permis
d'enrichir significativement le texte
qui vous est présenté aujourd'hui bon
nombre d'ajouts de 7 assemblée ont été
retenus dans la version finale du texte
je ne peux pas être exhaustif mais vous
me permettrez de mentionner un certain
nombre de mesures je pense à la
suppression de la condition d'âge du
décès de l'époux ancien combattant pour
le bénéfice par sa veuve d'une demi part
fiscale c'était porté par Didier Rambaud
notamment mais aussi par Jean-Jacques
Panunzi et par madame Jocelyne G
je pense à l'introduction d'un crédit
d'impôt l'un pour les entreprises
l'autre pour les particuliers sur les
dons aux communes et syndicats
forestiers pour certaines opérations de
gestion forestière c'est un sujet qui
était porté notamment par Vanina Paoli
Gaga et par le groupe des indépendants
qui étaient d'ailleurs au cœur d'une
proposition de loi adoptée en première
lecture ici dans cette émission du Sénat
je pense à l'établissement d'une base
légale à l'exonération d'impôts dont
bénéficie déjà les allocations versées
aux orphelins de victimes d'acte
antisémite et d'actes de barbarie durant
la Seconde Guerre mondiale à
l'initiative du sénateur marque Laménie
qui a porté cet amendement
concernant nos outre-mer nous avons
également intégré plusieurs amendements
importants je pense notamment à
l'amendement du rapporteur général de la
commission des finances visant à inclure
les collectivités d'outre-mer dans le
périmètre des dispositifs de
défiscalisation prorogée je veux
également mentionner la prolongation de
plusieurs dispositifs de défiscalisation
jusqu'en 2029 pour les collectivités
d'outre-mer à l'initiative du sénateur
tevaro frites je veux citer l'amendement
porté par le sénateur Georges passion
pour lutter contre l'habitat un salut
libre outremer je veux citer
l'amendement porté par la sénatrice
Michel Jacques sur la continuité
territoriale et la prise en charge des
billets d'avion pour nos compatriotes
ultramarins concernant la Corse nous
avons également retenu dans le texte
deux amendements défendus par
Jean-Jacques Panunzi l'un prévoit la
prorogation du crédit d'impôt en Corse
jusqu'en 2027 l'autre permet de garantir
l'éligibilité de ce même crédit d'impôt
aux résidences de tourisme
je veux donc rappeler que ce texte a
permis un enrichissement important par
le débat parlementaire c'est également
un texte de soutien à nos collectivités
territoriales qui comme l'état comme les
ménages et comme les entreprises sont
confrontées à une situation
exceptionnelle
bon nombre de mesures sont d'ailleurs
soit directement soit indirectement le
choix le résultat des échanges que nous
avons eu des compromis que nous avons su
construire malgré un certain nombre de
désaccords qui sont naturels légitimes
je crois en démocratie s'agissant de la
DGF ce PLF acte une augmentation de 320
millions d'euros c'est la première fois
depuis 13 ans que cette dotation connaît
une augmentation l'année prochaine grâce
à cet abonnement 95% des communes
verront leur DGF augmenter ou stabilisés
s'agissant de la suppression de la CVAE
nous garantissons une compensation à
l'Europe avec une fraction pérenne de
TVA la compensation sera calculée en
faisant une moyenne sur quatre années de
2020 à 2023 je sais que cela constitue
ici une préoccupation forte pour que les
bonnes années l'activité économique les
toutes dernières années puissent être
prises en compte dans le calcul
s'agissant du filet de sécurité celui-ci
sera étendu à l'ensemble des strates de
collectivité en l'espèce les
départements et les régions cette
version 2023 largement inspirée par les
travaux du Sénat et remanier de la façon
suivante nous supprimons le premier
critère d'éligibilité le seuil de perte
d'épargne brute est fixée à -15% au lieu
des 25% qui étaient prévus et la prise
en compte de seulement 50% de recettes
réelles de fonctionnement pour le calcul
de l'effet de ciseaux et donc de la
dotation
d'autres mesures en faveur des
collectivités locales ont par ailleurs
été retenus je pense à l'amendement de
Madame Gatel sur les communes nouvelles
je pense à l'amendement du sénateur
delcrow sur la dotation biodiversité
beaucoup d'autres mesures pourraient ici
être mentionnées et être cités comme
vous le savez notre soutien va se
poursuivre l'année prochaine pour aider
les communes à faire face à la flambée
des coûts de l'énergie
le dispositif des tarifs réglementés
d’électricité en 2023 pour les petites
communes et compléter par un amortisseur
électricité qui s'appliquera dès le
premier janvier concrètement cela veut
dire que les collectivités territoriales
qui ne sont pas éligibles aux bouclier
tarifaires seront également soutenus par
l'État et que quel que soit et ceux quel
que soit leur taille concrètement entre
180 et 500 euros du mégawattheure nous
prendrons en charge la moitié de leur
facture d'électricité cette baisse de
prix s'appliquera immédiatement sur la
facture c'est l'État qui se chargera de
verser la différence entre le prix de
marché et le prix fixé au fournisseur
d'énergie via les charges de CSPE et le
troisième étage de cette fusée c'est
évidemment le filet de sécurité dont le
montant par rapport à 2022 sera plus que
triplé et je précise que nous sommes
désormais proches pour le filet de
sécurité 2022 des 5000 communes ayant
bénéficié d'un acompte et je ne doute
pas que dans chacune et chacun dans
chacun de vos départements vous avez des
exemples de communes qui ont pu
bénéficier d'un acompte sachant que
certaines communes également ne fait le
choix de ne pas demander un acompte en
attendant que leur compte 2022 soit clos
pour être certaine de pouvoir bénéficier
d'un accompagnement je retire des débats
que nous avons eu le sentiment d'avoir
noué un véritable dialogue souvent un
véritable débat avec de vrais
divergences encore une fois mais qui
sont parfaitement légitimes oui je
réponds au sénateur bokeh qui est
intervenu tout à l'heure sur le sujet
nous avons fait le choix de prendre nos
responsabilités via l'utilisation du
49-3 puisque nous ne pouvons imaginer la
sixième puissance mondiale affrontée
2023 les poches vides sans budget nous
avons une responsabilité qui est de
donner à notre pays un budget de le
doter d'un budget nous avons constaté
effectivement vous avez rappelé les
dialogues de Bercy que dès la fin de
l'été l'ensemble des oppositions
représentées à l'Assemblée nationale on
t’indiqué que quel que soit les mesures
qui se trouveraient dans le budget elles
voterait contre et qu'elle nous
contradlerait d'utiliser le 49-3 nous
avons pendant plus d'une dizaine
d'heures réunies l'ensemble des
oppositions dans le cadre des dialogues
de Bercy pour leur demander précisément
quelle mesure leur permettrait de
reconsidérer leur position et de
d'envisager la possibilité de s'abstenir
voire même on peut toujours rêver de
voter favorablement le budget la réponse
a été immuable et a été la même aucune
mesure ne nous ferait changer d'avis le
vote du budget pour nous est un vote
symbolique votez le budget c'est faire
partie de la majorité ont-elles dit et
dans ces conditions quel que soit le
contenu de votre budget nous voterons
compte oui nous avons donc assumé nos
responsabilités via l'utilisation de
l'article 49.3 l'absence de budget pour
2023 ça aurait été l'absence de
revalorisation pour nos enseignants sur
leurs salaires ça aurait été l'absence
de moyens supplémentaires pour nos
armées dans un contexte géopolitique
particulièrement tendu ça aurait été une
hausse de la facture d'électricité et de
gaz pour les Français de 120% au lieu
des 15% que nous avons permis grâce à ce
budget
ça aurait été 3000 postes de policiers
et de gendarmes en moins pour la
sécurité des Français ça aurait été un
pays laissé
en insécurité face à de très forts aléas
qui existent aujourd'hui au niveau
mondial et au niveau européen nous avons
donc eu des débats et nous avons cherché
dans le courant de ces débats à faire au
mieux pour être au rendez-vous de la
protection des français tout en tenant
nos comptes publics nous aurons
l'occasion dans les prochains textes
dans les prochaines années je le
souhaite de discuter de ces sujets là et
de continuer à en débattre et à
travailler ensemble je le dis je
souhaite et j'espère que s'agissant du
Sénat cela se fera toujours dans le même
esprit de dialogue respectueux de nos
institutions respectueux de la
courtoisie et publicaine respectueux je
crois profondément des attentes des
Français qui attendent que nous nous
parlions et que nous travaillons
ensemble je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre quant à la
courtoisie républicaine je vous rassure
au Sénat c'est la règle
la parole est maintenant Monsieur
Jean-François Husson rapporteur général
de la commission des finances pour 10
minutes allez
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission mais chers collègues nous
allons examiner en nouvelle lecture le
PLF 2023 après l'usage une nouvelle fois
de la procédure du 49.3 l'Assemblée
nationale en effet la commission mix
paritaire qui s'est réunit le 6 décembre
n'a pu aboutir favorablement compte tenu
des divergences trop importantes sur les
237 articles restants en discussion
notons qu'en première lecture
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat avait
déjà adopté dans les mêmes termes 88
articles à l'issue de la nouvelle
lecture le texte considéré comme adopté
par l'Assemblée nationale qui est
finalement le vôtre monsieur le ministre
a parfois suivi le Sénat même
partiellement je vais en présenter
quelques exemples avant de vous indiquer
toutefois les nombreux désaccords qui
demeurent entre nos deux chambres parmi
les principaux apports du Sénat qui ont
été conservés par l'Assemblée nationale
bien sûr la suppression de l'article 40
quater du projet de loi tels que cons
comme adopté par l'Assemblée nationale
en nouvelle lecture c'est celui qui
consistait en réalité à réintroduire le
dispositif de contractualisation et de
sanctions souhaité par le gouvernement
pour les collectivités territoriales et
qui avait pourtant été rejeté par les
deux assemblées lors de l'examen du
projet loi programmation des finances
publiques ensuite je me félicite qui est
par exemple était conservée
l'exonération du malus pour les
véhicules des services départementaux
d'incendie et de secours mais aussi bien
sûr les mesures de financement portées
par notre président claudrénal pour les
lignes à grande vitesse plusieurs
mesures de progression ou d'amélioration
de dépenses fiscale permettent d'assurer
un soutien notamment économique et dans
la lutte contre l'habitat indigne aux
collectivités d'outre-mer qui font face
à des contraintes et des
difficultés spécifiques et il en est de
même pour la Corse j'aimerais jouis
aussi du maintien non pas de tous
de plusieurs dispositifs visant à lutter
contre la fraude fiscale et qui
constitue la traduction législative de
recommandations de notre mission
d'information
pilotée par la commission des finances
je veux également saluer le fait que le
texte reprenne la position du Sénat en
conservant sous réserve de diverses
aménagements l'essentiel des
modifications apportées dans la nouvelle
contribution sur la rente infra
marginale applicable au producteur
d'électricité pour autant s'agissant des
mesures fiscales et budgétaires
relatives à l'énergie je rappelle que le
Sénat a fait preuve d'un sens aigu des
responsabilités en votant des mesures
proposées par le gouvernement pour
lutter contre la hausse des prix
d'énergie et faire contribuer les
producteurs d'énergie à leur financement
conformément aux décisions prises au
niveau européen en effet je le rappelle
monsieur le ministre nous avons accepté
de voter dispositifs qui n'ont cessé
d'évoluer de façon majeure au cours de
la navette parle commentaires sans que
nous ayons pu disposer d'études d'impact
suffisamment solides ni même de tous les
éléments nous permettant de comprendre
parfaitement l'ensemble des enjeux des
modifications opérées sachez-le monsieur
le ministre nous serons particulièrement
attentifs à la mise en œuvre de tous ces
dispositifs et au fait qu'ils doivent
répondre effectivement besoin notamment
s'agissant du bouclier et de
l'amortisseur pour autant malgré ses
apports du Sénat des désaccords
importants subsistes entre les positions
de notre assemblée et le texte considéré
comme adopté par l'Assemblée nationale
et sur lequel le gouvernement engage sa
responsabilité on a tout d'abord eu
l'occasion d'exprimer nos réserves quant
aux prévisions de croissance pour 2023
une hypothèse de 1% qui est à ce jour
bien éloigné du consensus économiste et
surtout qui ne tient pas compte des
récents événements conjoncturels le
présent de la République lui-même
partage la vie du Sénat il publiquement
donc il faudrait que vous mettiez en
accord et que vous soyez en harmonie
avec le président quand la dette
publique atteint 100,5% du PIB la
remontée des taux d'intérêts constituent
un risque pour la soudabilité de notre
dette et si l'inflation est c'est vrai
mieux maîtriser en France que dans
d'autres économies développées c'est il
faut le dire au prix d'une forte
mobilisation de nos finances publiques
et il est donc indispensable de
poursuivre
si on doit poursuivre le soutien ménage
et aux entreprises il faut également
qu'un effort soit engagé pour maîtriser
la dépense ordinaire des administrations
publiques
pour le budget de l'État le gouvernement
fait en réalité le choix je l'ai dit
d'identifier les dépenses qui doivent
continuer à augmenter sans s'occuper des
économies qui doivent les compenser ça
n'est pas faire preuve de responsabilité
le déficit de l'État supérieur à 150
milliards d'euros pour la quatrième
année consécutive reste sur les sommets
atteints pendant la crise sanitaire et
ce budget est celui de tous les records
tant en termes de déficit présentant loi
de finance initiale que de niveau
d'emprunt nouveau alors s'agissant des
amendements adoptés par le Sénat je l'ai
dit un grand nombre d'entre eux n'ont
pas été conservés le rétablissement de
l'article 5 par le texte de nouvelle
lecture qui supprime la CVAE est opérée
sans que soit proposée de meilleure
garanties quant aux modalités de
compensation prévue pour les
collectivités territoriales pourtant
assurer une véritable financière de ces
collectivités et leurs capacité à
assumer les charges qui leur sont
imposées c'est cela monsieur le ministre
qu'il fallait comprendre aussi dans le
choix d'une majorité du Sénat de
supprimer cet article et donc de
contester la suppression de la cbae mais
cela ne remet pas en cause et en rien
notre soutien aux entreprises qui
doivent rester concurrentielles nous
avions poussé des mesures en faveur des
PME qui n'ont pas été retenus c'est le
rehaussement du plafond des bénéfices
soumis au taux d'iès tenant compte de
l'inflation ou encore la progression
pour un ennemi supplémentaire du
renforcement du crédit d'impôt pour les
travaux de rénovation énergétique
s'agissant des bâtiments à usage
tertiaire
pour revenir au finance locale
on pourrait se réjouir que sous la
pression du Sénat et du dispositif que
nous avions adopté le gouvernement était
contraint d'ouvrir davantage les
conditions d'éligibilité aux filets de
sécurité prévu pour ces mêmes
collectivités à l'article 14 stères
pourtant et je le regrette la
conservation du critère de perte
d'épargne brute même réduit à 15% est
une mauvaise nouvelle et pour deux
raisons d'abord il reste fortement
excluant et générateur d'importance des
faits de seuil et d'autre part il ne me
paraît pas
utile pour s'assurer que les
collectivités doivent être aidés dans la
mesure où les modalités même du calcul
de la dotation mais déjà en relation la
différence entre la progression des
dépenses est celle des recettes notre
proposition qui visait à rendre éligible
à plus grand nombre de collectivités
territoriales durement touchées par la
crise et donc détend la protection qu'il
aurait qui leur serait apporté était de
point de vue à la fois juste équitable
et raisonnable en effet elle devait
permettre aux collectivités cumulées ou
boucliers tarifaire et à l'amortisseur
électricité de regarder avec davantage
de sérénité l'arrivée des prochains mois
et la construction de leur budget
primitif il est d'ailleurs regrettable
que d'autres mesures de soutien aux
collectivité n'est pas été conservée à
l'exemple de l'intégration des
opérations d'aménagement et d'agencement
dans le FCTVA devenu inéligible par
suite de la réforme sur l'automatisation
de celui-ci je ne comprends d'ailleurs
pas non plus pourquoi la majorité
gouvernementale ne nous a pas à
rejoindre sur des abonnements pourtant
votés à la quasi uneanimité à l'exemple
du relèvement du plafond du prêt à taux
zéro qui doit permettre de soutenir
l'accession à la propriété des
primo-accédants sous condition de
ressources et dans un contexte de
durcissement des conditions d'emprunt
immobilier le texte considéré comme
adopté par l'Assemblée a également
rétabli les crédits des quatre missions
qui avaient été rejetées par le Sénat
sans pourtant qu'aucune réponse était
apportée
aux objections du Sénat
un sujet d'apparence technique monsieur
Nice aucun amendement qui a été adopté
par notre assemblée pour s'insériser le
budget n'a été conservé et nous avons
pourtant déjà la confirmation que le
gouvernement s'est bien aménagé une
confortable réserve de crédit au sein de
la dotation des dépenses accidentelles
et imprévisibles en effet
celle-ci est subitement réduite de 700
millions d'euros en nouvelle lecture
tandis que l'on retrouve cette même
somme dans la mission écologique pour
couvrir la nouvelle aide au carburant de
100 euros récemment annoncé ces crédits
tels qu'ils étaient inscrits dans le
texte initial avait donc une toute autre
destination ce n'est évidemment pas
satisfaisant pour législateur monsieur
le ministre vous le constatez les sujets
désaccords sont nombreux entre le Sénat
et la majorité gouvernementale la
commission des finances vous propose
donc d'opposer la question préalable sur
ce PLF pour 2023 et monsieur le ministre
je veux à cet instant conclure par
l'état d'esprit qui anime le
gouvernement à l'endroit des
collectivités territoriales j'entends
beaucoup de reproches faits ou
collectivités locales qui finalement
viendrait se nourrir sur le dos de
l'État mais la France des collectivités
monsieur le ministre elle n'est pas
l'ennemi de la République elle la sert
chaque jour alors faites-lui confiance
et donner à la France et au territoire
les meilleures chances pour agir et pour
l'avenir je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est d'abord au président
Jean-Claude Roquier pour le groupe RDSE
pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que reste-t-il de nos 160 heures de
débats et encore plus du travail
effectué à la mort et en commission sans
surprise le gouvernement est revenu sur
l'amendement de la majorité sénatoriale
prévoyant un dégâtement de la CVAE pour
les entreprises plutôt que sa
suppression sèche la suppression des
territorial qui mesure emblématique du
budget 2023 nous restons attentifs aux
modalités de compensation annoncée alors
auprès pour les collectivités
territoriales les contributions
exceptionnelles sur les bénéfices des
entreprises du secteur de l'énergie
entre eux également en vigueur bien que
les modifications techniques des
périmètres puissent encore être
apportées le diable est dans les détails
il existe un débat parmi les colonistes
sur le montant que rapporteront
effectivement ces contributions les
chiffres varient de plusieurs milliards
d'euros à seulement quelques centaines
de millions ce débat n'est pas sans
rappeler celui d'attaque Google sur les
services numériques mis en place en 2019
et qui le Kourou de nos partenaires
d'autres atlantiques quand il en soit
l'exécution du budget 2023 sera cruciale
elle dépendra plus que jamais de
l'évolution de la conjoncture
macroéconomique espérons qu'elle sera
plus favorable que ne l'affirme
certaines prévisionnistes parfois un peu
à l'armistes alors que le coup des
intérêts publics ont explosé en 2022
pour le reste le gouvernement
logiquement rétabli la plus grande
partie de son texte après la semaine
dernière la seconde partie les nombres
clés ici pour la majorité c'est latorale
ont été rétablies pour ma part je me
fais ici de la création nous avons
adopté sur le malus véhicule des
services et départementaux d'incendie de
secours ou encore le relèvement de la
dotation minimale aux communes pour la
protection de la biodiversité alors que
c'était ces derniers temps la coupe 15
sur la taxe d'aménagement la suppression
de la réforme de la répartition au sein
du bloc communal votez l'an dernier nous
paraît préférable dans la mesure où les
choses les charges d'aménagement varient
beaucoup en fonction de chaque
territoire
conforme l'article 40 quater sur les
nouveaux contrat état collectivité une
disposition originellement en procédant
de programmation qui a été introduite de
façon un peu surprenante dans les
articles non rattachés c'était le retour
des contrats de corps à ce sujet de vous
dire que les contrats de Cahors
retiennent aussi par le Premier ministre
Édouard Philippe non pas encore parce
que c'est le palais congrès mais la
fontanelbenque dans les champs de corps
maintenant disent que c'était pas chez
nous c'était à Fontaine d'albenque mais
actuellement
pour ces truffes que pour les contrats
la réforme de la Golf ajustement pour
effet positif de ramener ces fameux non
attachés à des propositions plus
raisonnables même si la proportion
détaille de la réforme a pu créer
quelques difficultés
sur la forme à la motion tendance à
opposer la question préalable même s'ils
en comprennent les motivations
merci monsieur le Président la parole
est maintenant monsieur Stéphane sotarel
pour le groupe les républicains pour 10
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
la commission mixte paritaire qui se
réunit le 6 décembre dernier n'est pas
parvenu à un accord en nouvelle lecture
le gouvernement a de nouveau déclenché
le 49-3 à deux reprises sur les parties
du projet de loi de finance monsieur le
ministre la déception est forte tout ça
pour ça
après 160 heures de séances au Sénat
l'examen de plus de 3000 amendements et
l'adoption de plus de 600 d'entre eux
très peu d'apports de notre haute
assemblée ont été retenus au final
le gouvernement une nouvelle fois fait
peu de cas du Parlement nous sommes
pourtant la seule chambre qui s'est en
est à examiner l'ensemble du texte nous
avons fait des propositions
constructives quasiment tout a été
balayé y compris celle adoptée à la
quasi unanimité du Sénat comme le prêt à
taux zéro comme la limitation des bonus
pour les véhicules électriques
je veux à cet instant saluer notre
travail collectif chers collègues tout
au long de la discussion malgré quelques
moments curieux et l'action de notre
rapporteur général toujours efficace et
bienveillante avec le seul souci de
l'intérêt général et pourtant vous
prétendez qu'une méthode nouvelle devait
être mise en place vous ne cessez de
demander à chacun à la droite
républicaine en particulier de
travailler avec vous dans l'intérêt du
pays en réalité la main que vous tendez
est un point fermé
à quoi bon perdre son temps dans les
pseudo dialogues de Bercy ou même dans
nos débats pour en arriver à se déni
total de notre régime parlementaire vous
ne voulez pas écouter alors même que
votre budget nous l'avions dénoncé dans
la discussion générale est un des pires
jamais présenté loin d'une gestion à
l'Europe trois chiffres seulement
500 milliards de dépenses publiques
d'État 270 milliards d'emprunt 27
milliards d'investissements je pourrais
ajouter le coût de la dette qui explose
tout cela dans une hypothèse de
croissance contestable de sincérité
interroger du budget et l'absence de
véritables boussole qui génère de
l'inquiétude dans l'ensemble de la
société malgré malgré pardon une
addiction ou quoi qu'il en coûte
en juillet dernier et de nouveau à la
rentrée le ministre de l'économie et des
finances Bruno Le Maire qui a déserté
nos bancs pendant quasiment toute la
discussion budgétaire mais effectivement
à quoi bon perdre son temps au Parlement
vous appelez à lui faire des
propositions d'économie je cite son
propos je propose que ce soit les
parlementaires qui se saisissent du
sujet et plus le gouvernement
je veux toutefois ouvrir une parenthèse
pour vous remercier Monsieur le Ministre
pour votre présence vos réponses même si
au final vous nous avez pas entendu ce
qui risque de rendre le dialogue plus
difficile demain que le gouvernement se
dessaisisse de la question de la
réduction de la dépense dans le contexte
de l'envolée de notre dette en disait
déjà beaucoup sur son manque de
responsabilité
mais qu'il ne reprennent au final aucune
de nos propositions d'économie alors
même qu'il nous avait mis au défi de lui
en proposer montre qu'encore une fois
tout cela n'était que de la
communication le calcul politique semble
plus important que l'intérêt du pays
nous avions pourtant proposé 4,3
milliards d'euros d'économie
conformément à la trajectoire que nous
avions votée dans le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques pas
un centime n'a été retenu
il allait de même des mesures que nous
avions votées pour venir un aide aux
entreprises aux collectivités
territoriales confrontés à une explosion
de leur facture énergétique
à une exception près que nous tenons à
saluer mais c'est la seule la
suppression du pacte de confiance entre
l'État et les 500 plus grandes
collectivités qui étaient en réalité
plutôt un acte de défiance à l'encontre
des élus locaux puisque des sanctions
étaient prévues en cas de non-respect de
ce pacte il n'avait d'ailleurs de pacte
que le nom puisqu'il est imposé au
collectivités visées et s'apparentait de
ce fait davantage à un contrat Léonard
en dehors de cette reprise importante du
Sénat aucun autre apport notable n'a été
retenu
à commencer par le la simplification du
filet de sécurité que nous vous avions
proposé le gouvernement a réintroduit
des critères les critères de baisse
d'épargne brut et de potentiel fiscal
cela a été rappelé vous avez préféré une
fois encore privilégier une machine
technocratique peu lisible pour les
collectivités plutôt qu'un système
simple transparent et au final sans
doute pas plus coûteux mais bien plus
vertueux pour les collectivités qui font
des efforts de gestion
il prend de nouveau comme référence
l'évolution des dépenses d'énergie entre
2022 et 2023 plutôt qu'entre 2021 et
2023 qui est pourtant le bon étalon de
mesure
par rapport à la version de l'Assemblée
nationale en première lecture le filet a
juste été un peu élargi avec une perte
d'épargne brute entre 23 et 22 qui doit
être supérieur à 15% au lieu de 25% et
un seuil de déclenchement correspondant
désormais à une hausse de dépenses
d'énergie supérieure à 50 % de la hausse
des recettes entre 22 et 23 et non plus
60 comme dans la version initiale
mais nous sommes très loin de la version
votée par le Cénac qui je le rappelle
prévoyez que toutes les collectivités
sans critères aucun aurait perçu une
dotation égale à 50% de la différence si
elle était positive entre l'augmentation
des dépenses d'énergie entre 23 et 21 et
40% de la hausse de ses recettes réelles
de fonctionnement sur la même période
je note plus largement que rien n'a été
retenu quant aux améliorations proposées
ou très peu au niveau des dotations au
collectivités sans même espérer leur
indexation pourtant justifier monsieur
le ministre un appel comme le rapporteur
général la fée de confiance en direction
des collectivités territoriales je pense
et de mise de surcroît nous regrettons
fortement que la réintégration des
opérations d'agencement et d'aménagement
de terrain dans l'assiette du FC TVA et
était supprimé c'était une demande très
forte des élus locaux vous aviez
pourtant déjà laissé entendre ici même à
notre dernier lors du PLFR puis lors de
l'examen de ce PLF que vous aviez
entendu cette demande légitime comment
rétablir la confiance en agissant ainsi
par ailleurs la suppression de la moitié
de la CVE en 2023 est rétabli concernant
la question de la territorialisation les
critères du nouveau fonds national
d'attractivité économique des
territoires ne sont toujours pas
précisées ils sont toujours renvoyés à
un décret ultérieur nous votons donc ce
dispositif à l'aveugle ce que nous
regrettons fortement
il y a là un véritable problème
démocratique comme le président de la
commission des finances l'a déjà rappelé
à plusieurs reprises l'essence même du
Parlement et de voter l'impôt cette
évolution de la CVAE quoi qu'on en pense
par ailleurs et vous savez que nous y
sommes favorables sur le principe Nora
bénéficié d'aucune approbation
parlementaire plus qu'un problème c'est
une alerte
concernant les entreprises nous n'avons
là aussi pas été entendu
la hausse plus importante du plafond du
taux réduit d'impôt sur les sociétés a
également été supprimées bien que le
gouvernement lui laissait entendre qu'en
compromis comme compromis était possible
il n'a rien il a été décidé de revenir
au texte initial à 42500 euros le
rossement du seuil d'entrée dans la
contribution sociale pour les bénéfices
de 7,63 à 10 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires annuel a également été
supprimé de même la hausse du taux
d'hier PME de 25 à 30% n'a pas été
reprise
j'aurais pu citer bien d'autres exemples
mais le temps est compté si nos
entreprises lâchent victimes de la crise
énergétique c'est notre pays tout entier
qui dévisse
je crains que les réponses qui sont
aujourd'hui qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui
à la hauteur de l'urgence
n'appelle des ajustements réguliers tout
au long de l'année 2023 si nous voulons
éviter le pire
au regard du peu de considération par le
gouvernement du travail réalisé par le
Sénat il ne servirait à rien de
réexaminer l'ensemble du budget et le
temps de nous le permettrait d'ailleurs
pas nous connaissons le sort de nos
amendements c'est la raison pour
laquelle le groupe les républicains
votera la question préalable déposée par
la commission des finances et que
présentera notre rapporteur général dans
quelques minutes je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Joël guerriot pour
le groupe les indépendants pour 4
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances ne sera pas en
général mes chers collègues le Sénat a
toujours su s'adapter selon l'évolution
des traditions concernant les projets de
loi de finances il semble qu'une
nouvelle tradition s'établissent le
rejet du texte en seconde lecture
certes le calendrier très contraint de
la loi organique des lois de finances
rend illusoire la poursuite des débats
sereins et approfondie mais notre groupe
regrette que le Sénat en soit contraint
à se priver d'un nouvel examen de ce
projet de loi de finance pour 2023 nous
le regrettons d'autant plus que le
pélève contient des mesures importantes
pour nos collectivités nos élus locaux
attendent un soutien fort pour lutter
contre l'inflation ces mesures sont
fortes et elles sont nombreuses à tel
point que nous devons désormais faire un
effort de pédagogie pour que nos
collectivités puissent tirer profit des
dispositifs qui seront mis en place en
2023 entre les annonces et grainées par
le gouvernement pendant tout l'automne
et les discussions parlementaires les
élus sont perdus ils ont besoin d'y voir
plus clair sur ce qui figure finalement
dans le texte nous prendrons notre part
pour faire connaître les dispositifs
mais la démarche doit être collective
cela vaut notamment pour le filet de
sécurité la commission des finances du
Sénat avait décidé de supprimer tous les
faire des ligibilités cela avait le
mérite de simplifier le dispositif et de
nescure aucune collectivité mais cela
risquait de ne pas optimiser la dépense
publique au profit des collectivités qui
en ont le plus besoin c'est pourquoi la
solution retenue par le gouvernement en
deuxième lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
ne me paraît plus raisonnable elle
réinterdit certains critères
d'éligibilité nous dispositif est à la
fois plus généreux que celui qui était à
l'issue de la première lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale et plus
restrictive que ce celui qui avait été
voté au Sénat il s'agit donc d'une
solution intermédiaire je remarque
d'ailleurs que le critère d'une perte
d'épargne brut de 15% correspond à ce
que notre groupe avait proposé par la
voie d'un sous amendement à l'amendement
du rapporteur général il permettra de
couvrir la majorité des collectivités
impactées par la hausse des coûts de
l'énergie
ce n'est pas une solution idéale mais
c'est une solution raisonnable elle ne
résoudra pas toutes les difficultés des
collectivités mais elle limitera
largement l'impact de l'inflation sur
les finances locales en outre le filet
de sécurité de constituent qu'un des
volets du mécanisme de soutien pour les
plus petites communes le bouclier
tarifaire continuera de s'appliquer en
2023 et pour les communes qui ne
seraient pas éligibles ni aux bouclier
tarifaires ni aux filets de sécurité il
restera l'amortisseur électricité enfin
pour terminer mes chers collègues je
voudrais revenir sur deux sujets
importants pour notre groupe le premier
concerne la préservation de nos forêts
le PLF intègre deux articles reprenant
les dispositifs de la proposition de loi
inscrite dans l'espace réservé de notre
groupe il s'agit d'ouvrir le dispositif
du mécénat pour les particuliers comme
pour les entreprises au don effectuées
au bénéfice des communes forestières le
suggest second sujet concerne les
communes nouvelles une solution de court
terme a été trouvée mais plusieurs
d'entre elles restent
j'espère que nous pourrons convenir et
continuer à les soutenir nous pouvons
nous féliciter de la qualité des débats
en première lecture avec un nouveau
record d'amendements analysé de 3707
amendements au cours de 160 heures en
séance certes monsieur le ministre des
comptes publics vous nous promettiez de
conserver des avancées proposées par
notre institution cependant le groupe
Les Indépendants trouvent dommages que
nous ne soyons pas en mesure de
peaufiner le texte en seconde lecture
merci
je vous remercie chers collègues la
parole est maintenant Monsieur Daniel
Breuillet pour le groupe écologiste pour
4 minutes vous avez la parole chers
collègues
sur le président monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances puis le rapporteur général
article 14 termes je cite si le épargne
brut enregistré en 2023 une baisse de
plus de 15% un peu plus loin parmi les
communes et les établissements publics
de coopération intercommune à la
fiscalité propre sol sont éligibles au
versement de la dotation susmentionnée
d'une part les communes dont le
potentiel financier par habitant est
inférieur à deux fois le potentiel
financier moyen par habitant de
l'ensemble des communes appartenant au
même groupe démographique défini à
l'article
l234-3 du Code Général des Collectivités
Territoriales monsieur le ministre merci
d'avoir simplifié le filet de sécurité
pour que les collectivités puissent
faire face à la hausse du coût de
l'énergie il est vrai que le Sénat avec
l'amendement du rapporteur général ne
considérant que la hausse des dépenses
et celle des recettes avec construit une
version pas assez technocratique pour
Bercy et trop lisible pour les mers
qui touche se demande comment il
boucleront leur budget cet exemple
monsieur le ministre illustre le
traitement réservé à nos 160 heures de
débats et aux 3000 et quelques
amendements discutés vous êtes dénué
d'une majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
mais vous continuez à gouverner sol dans
un entretien dangereux pour la
démocratie et pour nos institutions vous
avez fait votre tri sélectif dans les
amendements votés pour revenir via le
49.3 à une maquette à peine modifiée du
texte initial présenté à l'Assemblée
nationale au fond pour l'essentiel vous
avez retenu les amendements
gouvernementaux adieu la TVA 5,5 pour
les transports collectifs adieu
l'indexation de la DGF pourtant voter
par une très large majorité sur tous les
bancs adieu aussi les 8 milliards de CVA
vivent la dette publique sur le plan
écologique ce qui restera au bout de ce
texte et bien malheureusement pas grand
chose quelques mesures bienvenue mais
hommages mais en tout cas rien qui ne
soit la hauteur des crises climatiques
et de l'effondrement du vivant que les
cops ne cessent de démontrer sans qu'au
fond vous osiez les changements
indispensables 20 fois plus d'argent
pour le bouclier tarifaire que pour ma
prime rénove 100 milliards consacrés en
deux ans aux diffèrent boucliers il
manque cruellement à la transition
écologique il y a quelques semaines en
ouvrant nos débats je vous questionnais
monsieur le ministre en vous demandant
respecterez vous le travail du Parlement
cette question est sérieuse monsieur le
ministre la crise démocratique que nous
vivons appellerait une volonté et une
capacité à entendre le Parlement des
syndicats des ONG et les citoyens
certes le 49-3 est constitutionnel
évidemment vous faites bien d'ailleurs
de ne pas laisser un texte qui supprime
cinq missions budgétaires pour suivre
son chemin mais ça ne justifie pas de ne
rien retenir ou presque de nos débats
l'inutilité de nos débats et des noms
débats de place au rassemblement
national qui en profite pour apporter
ces mauvaises réponses à de bonnes
questions et pendant que nous sommes
toutes et tous les protagonistes d'une
comédie burlesque sur l'inutilité
parlementaire une partie des Français
tombe dans le tragique l'inflation et
les prix de l'alimentation explosent et
ce ne sont plus les fins de moi qui sont
difficiles mais parfois le 10 du mois
les coupures d'électricité inquiète la
crise énergétique préoccupe les Français
et les désarçonnent tout autant quand
engie vit une année 2022 records avec un
chiffre d'affaires augmenté de 85% sur
les 9 premiers mois à 69,3 milliards
d'euros vos déclarations publiques
annoncées la poursuite des décisions
jupitériennes
ignorant le Parlement comme vous ignorez
les partenaires sociaux avec votre
prochaine réforme néfastes des retraites
monsieur le ministre on a rarement
raison seul la démocratie sans Parlement
et sans parle sans partenaire sociaux ce
n'est déjà plus la démocratie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur André gatelin pour
le groupe RDP pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Messieurs les Présidents et
rapporteurs généreux du de la commission
des finances mes chers collègues la
commission des finances précisément s'y
réunissent ce matin pour déposer une
motion tendante à opposer la question
préalable nous priverons ainsi du débat
en nouvelle lecture sur ce projet de loi
de finance comme chaque année notre
groupe déplore cette posture mais cette
année nous regrettons si vous voulez
plus particulièrement de ne pas pouvoir
discuter des engagements forts de ce
budget pour la protection des Français
et des collectivités locales des apports
du Sénat qui ont été retenus dans la
navette messieurs car aucun gouvernement
précédent ne l'avait fait ce budget
consacre le réarmement de nos forces de
sécurité avec une hausse de 7% de leurs
moyens le ministère de la Justice quant
à lui
son budget augmenté de 8% pour la
troisième année consécutive pour le
ministère de l'éducation c'est
l'objectif le plus ambitieux de ces
dernières années pas un enseignant à moi
de 2000 euros nets par mois en début de
carrière pour les ménages nous rendons
plus de 6 milliards d'euros de pouvoir
d'achat avec l'indexation du barème de
l'impôt sur le revenu la reconduction du
bouclier tarifaire permettent également
de protéger le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages mais aussi des entreprises et
des collectivités locales avec
l'amortisseur électricité et le filet de
sécurité c'est le système de protection
le plus complet et le plus ambitieux mis
en place en Europe alors au cours de la
navette le gouvernement il est députés
ont conservé des apports importants du
Sénat venus de tout bon je ne les
rappellerai pas le ministre les a
longuements et numérique précédemment
notre groupe aussi a apporté sa pierre à
l'édifice mais
dépit de tous ses efforts pour protéger
les Français et pour réarmer nos
services publics en dépit des nombreuses
concessions faites la majorité
sénatoriale choisit de nous priver de ce
débat et de se dessaisir elle-même de sa
responsabilité depuis des semaines vous
nous accusez de négligence budgétaire
alors que vous n'avez fait que adopter
de nouvelles dépenses tout au long de
l'examen en première lecture et je vous
le dis et l'article 5 sur la CVAE que
vous avez rejeté après avoir pris tant
de peine à le réécrire ni change rien
messieurs l'échec de la commission mixte
paritaire sur la loi de programmation
des finances publiques ce matin est une
triste illustration de ces incohérences
vous dénoncez une trajectoire peu
ambitieuse et réclamer des efforts plus
importants soit mais je vous rappelle
que vous n'avez pas pu respecter la
trajectoire que vous vouliez fixer pour
2023 dans la loi de programmation c'est
à dire - 4,6% de points de PIB il vous
aura donc fallu improviser une seconde
délibération sur un certain nombre
d'amendements de la première partie pour
afficher un déficit à peine en recul et
parlons-en vous n'êtes parvenu à cet
assez piètre résultat qu'au prix du
rejet en bloc du budget de l'agriculture
pas moins de la vision mission cohérence
des territoires de la mission
immigration et de la mission engagement
financier de l'État alors mes chers
collègues et c'est les paroles d'un
futur retraité de la vie parlementaire
donc amical mes chers collègues de la
majorité je vous apprécie tous
personnellement et individuellement mais
à l'image d'une équipe de foot qui perd
vous omettez de vous parler entre vous
et d'agir collectivement et en cohérence
sur le terrain au poids très souvent de
en hémicycle à des votes en total
contradiction avec vos choix en
commission alors vous l'avez compris le
groupe RDPI votre a compte cette motion
de rejet préalable je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Eric jansanettaz
pour le groupe socialiste pour 6 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
nous arrivons donc au terme du marathon
budgétaire 2022 moment phare de chaque
session parlementaire il est normalement
le théâtre des grands arbitrages qui
guideront l'action publique pour l'année
à venir moment phare car député et
sénateur enrichissent le texte pour
répondre au mieux aux préoccupations des
concitoyens des territoires et des
territoires que nous représentons bien
sûr la commission mixte n'est pas
conclusive bien sûr la question
préalable sera votée et nous la voterons
dommage car nombre par le 49.3 le
Sénat a pu travailler nous avons même
produit un nombre record d'amendements
300035 au total dans environ 600 adoptés
et passer de nombreuses heures avec vous
monsieur le ministre et nous vous en
remercions dans cette émission
pour ne parler que du groupe socialiste
nous en avons proposé 282 donc 41
adoptés
le Sénat a pleinement joué son rôle dans
la navette parlementaire dont on cherche
malheureusement aujourd'hui le sens et
l'utilité
nous n'allons pas utiliser ces minutes
afin de parler de la dixième utilisation
consécutive de l'article 49 à Linéa 3
par votre gouvernement en quelques
semaines les élus les partis politiques
la presse et les Français le font
suffisamment pour que je l'espère vous
ayez pris la mesure et le poids de ces
décisions sur la perception de notre
nation à de ces politiques de son
gouvernement et de ses élus au nom du
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains je déplore le manque de
responsabilité dont a fait preuve le
gouvernement je le déplore car votre
budget avait besoin du Sénat notamment
pour faire cesser le mépris que vous
entretenez vis-à-vis de nos
collectivités territoriales d'ailleurs
ce PLF ne protège pas plus les
collectivités que nos concitoyens face à
l'inflation
voilà une occasion manquée pour la
majorité relative du président de tenir
compte du scrutin législatif de juin à
l'Assemblée la succession de 49,3 est
allée jusqu'à défaire les votes
intervenus pour établir un texte
l'intégrant que 99% des propositions que
de votre majorité
au Sénat ensuite vous faites le choix de
ne rien retenir aussi peu de nos
propositions en témoignent tout
naturellement l'échec de cette CMP qui
avons le était écrit d'avance
nous avons donc désormais un texte
finalisé dans l'attente de l'analyse
vigilante du Conseil constitutionnel sur
lequel nous pouvons nous prononcer
disons-le d'emblée le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain vous le savez
monsieur le ministre votre rencontre au
niveau des recettes le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains a tenté en
vain il faut bien l'admettre de
rééquilibrer le budget ce budget et en
particulier de proposer une fiscalité
plus juste plus équitable et plus
adaptée aux activités économiques
sociales et sociales actuelles nos
propositions de justice sociale de bon
sens même en tout simplement été balayé
tant par la majorité sénatoriale que par
le gouvernement en effet disons-le sans
ambage alors que l'urgence sociale est
indéniable vous partagez en matière de
recettes exactement la même vision et
vous portez les mêmes propositions
libérales face à l'inflation galopante
la fraternité devrait être le maître mot
de l'action publique mais vous tous avez
fait le choix de vous obstiner de
poursuivre sur la voie du libéralisme
rejet de l'établissement du
rétablissement de l'ISF de la taxation
des super profits réticences au
verdissement de la fiscalité alors où
sont et où est le consensus et la
recherche de compromis avec l'ensemble
des forces républicaines au niveau des
dépenses malgré la mise en échec
systématique de nos propositions en
matière de recettes alors que cela vous
aurait donné des marges budgétaires
supplémentaires nous avons tenu à vous
faire de nouvelles propositions
malheureusement force est de constater
que maintenir les services publics dans
les territoires notamment ruraux
n'étaient pas votre priorité hôpitaux
école bureau de poste n'était pas au
cœur de ce budget et nous le déplorons
c'est indifférence pour le terrain
s'illustre aussi par le sort réservé aux
collectivités territoriales toutes
alerte sur les difficultés de
financement face aux crises que nous
subissons pourtant monsieur le ministre
vous avez fait fi de l'adoption par le
Sénat de la proposition socialeiste d'un
excès la DGF sur l'inflation je ne peux
pas passer sous silence non plus votre
entêtement à supprimer la CVAE pourtant
sauvé par le Sénat sur proposition de la
gauche finalement vous aurez réussi
l'exploit de présenter une copie qui ne
satisfera aucun élu local et aucune
association représentative de ces
derniers il faut le souligner avec cette
inflation conséquente la sortie de crise
sanitaire la guerre aux portes de
l'Europe notre pays aurait besoin d'un
État fort votre politique au contraire
se base sur deux fondamentaux clairs le
désarmement fiscal en matière de
recettes et la contraction des
interventions de l'État en matière de
dépenses
en cela somme toute monsieur le ministre
alors que votre gouvernement prétend à
renouveler les modes d'exercice du
pouvoir et à incarner une forme de
modernité le constat est radicalement
différent et je partage le constat de
notre collègue Eric Bocquet vous portez
une politique libérale pour ne pas dire
ultra libéral aux antipodes des besoins
de notre pays et de notre population
c'est pourquoi nous ne pouvons que nous
opposer à ce projet de loi de finance
pour 2023
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Pascal ça vole Delhi
pour le groupe CRCE pour 4 minutes
ce président sur le ministre mes chers
collègues
ce budget est placé sous le saut de la
contrainte des coups de force répétées
sur les débats parlementaires au gré de
la dizaine de 49-3 et là vous venez nous
dire monsieur le ministre fermeté
ah bah s'il y a un événement de fermeté
ouais c'est vrai c'est bien une nouvelle
étape de la confiscation du pouvoir
alors vous faites mine de gagner
face à une alternative de gauche par
exemple
mais votre budget sera adopté sans vote
sur le ministre et on gagne jamais
contre la démocratie
les administrations publiques la
sécurité sociale ou les collectivités
territoriales font face à un
gouvernement qui fuit ses
responsabilités ce budget marque le
désengagement par exemple de l'État sur
le financement de la formation continue
via le compte personnel de formation
détriment des travailleurs et de
l'apprentissage dans la fonction
publique territoriale au détriment des
collectivités enfin en vérité c'est le
partage de la valeur créée qui est sans
cesse raboter sans cesse volée au
travailleuses et au travailleur c'est un
angle mort de votre budget le partage de
la valeur c'est accroître la
contribution du capital en mobilisant
les transactions financières les
dividendes ou les bénéfices par exemple
mais c'est aussi s'interdire de faire
payer les mesures de soutien au ménage
et aux collectivités par l'ensemble des
concitoyens des concitoyens derrière
vous créez une fiction ce que vous
prétendez aider ce qui subissent ici
l'explosion des prix de l'énergie où là
des denrées alimentaires sont les mêmes
les mêmes qui vont faire contribuer au
47 milliards d'euros du bouclier
tarifaire
il le finance alors vous savez comment
par la baisse des droits du chômage par
l'allongement du temps de travail dans
la semaine et dans la vie par la baisse
en euros courant de l'impôt sur le
revenu des plus riches par la
suppression de l'amendement adoptée pour
baisser la TVA sur le transport
ferroviaire votre politique ne soutient
pas les plus précaires elle fait ma
région clairement des perdants sur le
ministre et face au Christ systémiques
être en responsabilité en termes
signifiait pour nous préserver ses
sentinelles de la République ce dernier
rempart que sont les collectivités
territoriales lorsque l'État est rendu
défaillant d'un côté ce budget prive les
collectivités des recettes de fiscalité
économiques en supprimant la CVE de
l'autre l'indexation de la DGF sur
l'inflation pourtant une priorité
absolue est un amputée de 4% en euros
courant le filet dit de sécurité est un
filet consciemment malticé bien loin du
bouclier indispensable pour équilibrer
leur budget oui vous m'avez bien entendu
monsieur le ministre équilibré leur
budget parce que les collectivités ont
cette obligation qui n'est celle de
l'État
et sous l'impulsion des élus locaux et
de notre groupe le Sénat l'avait
amélioré mais le ministre des Finances
là encore restreint est pris ainsi des
milliers de communes c'est un signal
extrêmement préoccupant que votre
gouvernement voit aux collectivités les
départements alors aussi vont empathie
et devront constater que la modeste
revalorisation du RSA pèsera 240
millions d'euros en 2023
sans cesse le RSA d'ailleurs est de plus
en plus conditionné à la fin pour la fin
des fins et la fin est faim aussi des
fois pour certains c'est toujours les
prétextes les précaires qui payent
quittant faire des travailleurs
rémunérés et j'ai fait un petit calcul
vous savez à combien ils sont rémunérés
au salaire minimum estonien belle
référence non enfin gouvernement tente
de diviser les collectivités
territoriales entre elles alors là c'est
quoi encore d'insister la métropole du
Grand Paris contre les établissements
publics territoriaux les communes
rurales contre les communes urbaines les
départements selon leur potentiel
financiers les autres les autorités
organisatrices de mobilité
d'Île-de-France et d'ailleurs et la
concrétisation de ce projet dangereux
est encore au détriment des habitants
qui voient reculer leurs services
publics et des usagers qui constatent
une baisse de la cadence des transports
publics avec ce fameux en même temps
qu'une hausse du Navigo par exemple en
Île-de-France j'étais avec les maires du
département mardi dernier pour partager
leurs colères et sentiments de
dépossession de leur capacité d'action
face à des choix cornéliens Premier
ministre les élus locaux doivent choisir
entre fermer leurs écoles ou d'autres
services publics essentiels tels que par
exemple les centres d'action sociale
l'état transfert sa responsabilité sur
les élus locaux privés de leur fiscalité
de leur dotation et non même de faire
face à leurs dépenses vous avez ce
budget une seule idéologie l'argent à
l'argent pour toutes ces raisons
l'intérêt général des temporaire vous
nous allons nous opposer à votre projet
de loi de finances merci de votre
attention merci chers collègues la
parole est maintenant madame Sylvie
vermillier pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 6 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
après trois mois de travail en
commission et trois semaines d'un examen
intensif mais attentif en séance
publique avec pas moins de 3000
amendements en discussion nous voici
réunis pour nous prononcer sur le projet
de loi de finance pour 2023 adopter en
nouvelle lecture par l'Assemblée
nationale après engagement par le
gouvernement de sa responsabilité sur le
fondement de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution nous vous le disons
clairement monsieur le ministre nous
regrettons qu'un aussi grand nombre de
mesures adoptées par le Sénat n'est pas
été prise en compte par l'Assemblée
nationale et le gouvernement dans le
texte final
Bruno Le Maire nous avait indiqué en
ouverture des débats être à l'Europe
visiblement il n'est pas aux milliard
prêt plusieurs mesures volontaristes de
rationalisation des niches fiscales
autrement dit d'optimisation des
ressources publiques adoptées à
l'initiative du groupe Union centriste
ont ainsi été balayés d'un revers de
main par l'exécutif sans la moindre
explication ni même parfois le moindre
chiffrage de la part de Bercy
les crises sont devenus omniprésentes et
il nous faut composer avec elle la
multiplication de ces crises a pour
inéluctable conséquences de détériorer
la situation de long finance publique or
le resserrage du robinet budgétaire par
la Banque centrale européenne et la
remontée consécutive des taux d'intérêt
sur les marchés financiers nous invite
collectivement à la responsabilité c'est
dès l'année prochaine qu'il aurait fallu
engager les comptes de l'État sur la
voie du redressement plusieurs
amendements de notre groupe qui une fois
de plus aura eu le sens de ses
responsabilités y aurait contribué
nous l'avons dit à l'issue de la
première partie et nous vous le redisons
aujourd'hui nous regrettons de ne pas
être parvenu à élargir la contribution
exceptionnelle de solidarité à
l'ensemble des secteurs d'activités
économiques au-delà du seul secteur de
l'énergie s'il est parfaitement légitime
que la collectivité publique Vienne aux
chevets des entreprises lorsqu'elles
sont en difficulté il est non moins
légitime que ces mêmes entreprises
lorsqu'elles sont en meilleure santé
concourent à l'effort collectif
d'assainissement des comptes publics de
même la suppression de l'article 5
autrement dit le maintien de la CVAE
perçu par le bloc communal et des
départements auraient permis à la sphère
publique de sauvegarder immédiatement
près de 4 milliards d'euros de recettes
fiscales tout en préservant l'autonomie
financière des collectivités locales
malmenées depuis de trop nombreuses
années
parmi les mesures adoptées pour soutenir
nos collectivités territoriales
figuraient la réintégration dans le
fonds de compensation pour la TVA des
opérations d'aménagement et d'agencement
qui y étaient devenus inéligibles du
fait de la réforme de l'automatisation
nous avions volontairement laissé de
côté les opérations d'acquisition par
souci là encore dans limiter le coût
pour les finances publiques le
gouvernement naïlase pas conserver la
disposition du Sénat pourtant légitime
est nécessaire au regard des
investissements élevés engagés par les
collectivités
par ailleurs nous avions
substantiellement simplifié et renforcer
le filet de sécurité pour le rendre
accessible à un plus grand nombre de
collectivités touchées par la crise
énergétique et afin de leur permettre
d'aborder plus sereinement les échéances
à venir
le gouvernement lui-même semblait
admettre la trop grande complexité des
critères retenus dans le dispositif au
titre de l'année 2022 or que fait-il
pour l'année 2023 après recours aux 49.3
il réintroduit ses mêmes critères au
détriment de l'intelligibilité du
mécanisme et donc en fin de compte des
élus locaux malgré ses griefs nous
tenons monsieur le ministre à vous
remercier pour nos échanges toujours
positifs et constructifs tout au long
des débats ainsi que pour votre
disponibilité et vos positions
argumentées nous sommes en revanche
nombreux à déplorer l'absence répétée
réserve faite de l'ouverture de la
discussion générale initiale du ministre
de l'économie et des finances sur des
sujets aussi cruciaux pour l'avenir du
pays nous pensions que la configuration
politique actuelle pouvait contribuer à
ses yeux à la revalorisation du rôle du
Sénat
sans surprise la commission mixte
paritaire qui s'est réunie le 6 décembre
dernier n'a pu aboutir favorablement
comme la rappeler le rapporteur général
un trop grand nombre d'articles restés
en discussion
contenu non seulement de l'échec de la
CMP mais également d'aider les prévus
par la Constitution qui rendent
impossible l'examen complet du texte en
nouvelle lecture le groupe Union
centriste adoptera quasi unanimement la
motion tendant à opposer la question
préalable je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la discussion
générale est close nous passons à la
discussion de la motion tendance à
opposer la question préalable Monsieur
Jean-François Husson au nom de la
commission des finances à déposer une
motion distribuée sous le numéro 2 tu en
as opposé la question préalable au texte
en discussion la parole est au
rapporteur général oui monsieur le
Président Monsieur ministre je vous
épargner le temps de parole de 10
minutes
puisque c'est un peu de dans l'air du
temps je vais éviter de jouer les
prolongations qui me paraissent à ce
stade relativement
inutile je vais également éviter de me
répéter même si je pense que parfois il
vaut mieux se répéter que ce qu'on peut
dire
une question préalable finalement
elle a tendance ça a été dit à écourter
le débat de manière un peu brutale mais
pour tout vous dire avec les contraintes
juridiques qui tiennent à la procédure
d'examen du projet de loi de finance il
eût fallu trouver entre maintenant et
demain soir minuit une solution qui
puisse convenir à notre assemblée avant
de renvoyer la copie au gouvernement et
notamment à l'Assemblée alors je vais
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire dans la
déclaration tout à l'heure
je crois monsieur le ministre
qu'il faut à cet instant être très
attentif
sur la question budgétaire à trouver de
la cohérence ici au Sénat nous vous
avons tracé des perspectives et nous
avons tenu la route on a tracé des
perspectives de responsabilité et
d'efforts pour maîtriser la dépense en
la concentrant plus et en ciblant les
efforts que notre pays doit effectuer
vous avez considéré que ces efforts
étaient
inutiles puisque aucun d'entre eux n'a
été repris par le gouvernement c'est
votre responsabilité mais sachez que
nous serons je serai pour ma part très
attentif autant de fois que j'entendrai
des prises de position considérant
qu'aucune piste d'économie n'a été
trouvée ici nous avons fait nous avons
proposé plus de 4 milliards d'économies
la trajectoire conforme conforme
conforme aux engagements que nous avons
mis en perspective pour la trajectoire
au sujet d'ailleurs de laquelle dans la
programmation des finances publiques
nous avons il y a quelques minutes
échouées dans
l'attentative de rapprochement je pense
monsieur le ministre aussi que vous
dites il faut sortir du quoi qu'il en
coûte mais alors prenez aussi vos
responsabilités la responsabilité du
gouvernement mis en place à la suite de
l'élection de la rédélection du
président de la République aujourd'hui
c'est de faire travailler la France et
les deux assemblées au regard du choix
des Français à l'Assemblée nationale et
avec le Sénat vous utilisez les 49,3
c'est votre droit constitutionnel à
l'Assemblée et ici vous êtes dans une
opération très agréable d'écoute le
débat les débats se passent fort bien
mais vous retenez plutôt et je le dis
parce que ça nous concerne également les
uns les autres des amendements de porter
moindres que les enjeux majeurs et je
vous le redis une question majeure à
côté de laquelle vous êtes passé et je
fais le pari que nous nous retrouverons
à l'ami 2023 pour corriger les
insuffisances notamment du filet de
sécurité pour les collectivités locales
je terminerai d'ailleurs par là ce sujet
du filet de sécurité et des contrats
énergétiques va peser certainement
gravement dès le début de cette année
sur notre outil de production c'est à
dire nos entreprises monsieur le
ministre le
dispositif dont nous avons eu à
connaître et à débattre qui d'ailleurs
n'est pas complètement stabilisé entre
l'amortisseur électricité le filet de
sécurité le bouclier tarifaire nous
avons demandé au gouvernement et vous
avez donné un accord de principe sur le
fait que nous allons le suivre moi après
moi parce que il nous paraît
indispensable de faire en sorte que les
élus soient aux côtés des territoires et
notamment des acteurs économiques
puisqu'il n'y aura pas en France de
sortie de crise sans une attention et
une économie à notre économie et donc
une économie qui soit aussi dynamique
que possible voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire à cet instant et puis faire
une témoin de me dire puisque c'est la
fin du budget il a été ouvert sur par le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
sur le principe d'être à l'Europe
il est conclu avec une dérive
supplémentaire de 6 à 7 milliards alors
évidemment je comprends qu'il soit
difficile de faire des économies nous a
proposé plus de 4 milliards d'économies
vous rendez une copie avec plus de 6
milliards par rapport à la copie
initiale c'est donc plus le quoiqu'il en
coûte c'est donc plus à l'Europe c'est
finalement une poursuite d'une dérive
budgétaire qui ne manque pas de nous
inquiéter parce que dans le même temps
la dette s'accroît les taux d'intérêt
sont en train de s'élever ce qui va
avoir des conséquences pour la dette de
la France c'est d'être financière et
budgétaire qui pèse sur chaque français
et qui s'ajoute je le redis une fois de
plus ici à une dette écologique et
climatique qui est préoccupante pour
chacune et chacun d'entre nous d'où vous
l'avez compris la question préalable
pour finalement
la difficulté dans laquelle le
gouvernement se met dans la discussion
parlementaire
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
avait du gouvernement naturellement
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
évidemment un avis défavorable du
gouvernement à cette question préalable
et je veux dire
ma déception puisque j'aurais souhaité
qu'on puisse reprendre la discussion le
débat le travail ensemble pour cette
nouvelle lecture du projet de loi de
finances qu'on puisse à nouveau se
plonger dans le fond des sujets et avoir
un débat parfois un projet contre projet
mais en tout cas qu'on puisse échanger
je comprends que ça ne sera pas possible
puisque la majorité sénatoriale votera
cette question préalable je regarderai
les votes des groupes politiques qui
nous ont reproché avec le 49-3 d'abréger
les débats à l'Assemblée nationale et
qui de fait abrège les débats au Sénat
ici en votant la question préalable moi
je suis favorable au débat et à la
discussion autant qu'elle peut se tenir
c'est vrai monsieur le rapporteur
général
c'est vrai qu'il y a des dépenses
supplémentaires à la fin de cet examen
budgétaire par rapport au début de
l'examen budgétaire j'ai envie de dire
encore heureux puisque précisément s'il
y a des dépenses supplémentaires c'est
que nous avons tenu compte des
propositions des ajouts qui ont été
portées que ce soit à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat vous avez cité le
chiffre de 7 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires sur ces 7 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires 5 milliards 500
millions d'euros sont des dépenses
supplémentaires en direction des
collectivités locales le pas d'un côté
nous reprocher de ne pas suffisamment
soutenir les collectivités locales et de
l'autre côté quand on le fait nous
reprocher de dépenser trop je pense que
l'important c'est que ce projet de loi
de finances est entré dans cette
assemblée en l'occurrence d'abord à
l'Assemblée nationale avec un déficit de
5% pour 2023 et qu'il sort de nos débats
avec un déficit de 5% pour 2023
contretemps il y a eu des dépenses
supplémentaires et qu'elles sont
financées par l'augmentation des
recettes liées à la taxation des super
profits que nous avons décidé au niveau
européen et qui se traduit oui j'ose le
terme j'ose le terme de taxation des
super profits et qui se traduit dans ce
texte et oui bah oui on progresse tous
on évolue tous aussi voilà cet été on
parlait pas forcément dans ces termes
mais voilà passer du temps au Sénat
finalement ça ça forge un homme ça vous
fait évoluer et donc effectivement il y
a 11 milliards d'euros de recettes en
plus lié à la taxation des super profits
dans le secteur énergétique grâce au
dispositif que nous avons décidé au
niveau européen et ça permet de financer
des mesures supplémentaires pour la
protection des Français alors c'est vrai
il y a un certain nombre de propositions
d'économie issues du texte adopté par la
majorité sénatoriale que nous n'avons
pas retenu c'est vrai que j'ai pas
retenu la suppression du ministère de
l'Agriculture ni la suppression du
ministère de la cohésion des territoires
ni la suppression de l'administration
territoriale de l'État un moment où les
Français ont besoin de pouvoir faire
leur carte d'identité ou leur passeport
c'est vrai que je n'ai pas retenu et que
nous n'avons pas retenu la limitation
c'est un vrai débat que nous avons eu
pour le coup un beau débat la limitation
de la prise en charge du bonus
écologique et de la prime à la
conversion pour les véhicules
électriques c'est vrai qu'il y a une
position qui a été très marquée de la
part de la majorité sénatoriale sur le
fait que aujourd'hui et on le déplore
tous aujourd'hui c'est un soutien
financier public qui va vers une
induction une industrie qui n'est pas
l'industrie française ou européenne
plutôt l'industrie chinoise puisque nous
ne produisons pas suffisamment de
véhicule électrique aujourd'hui il ne
vous aura pas échappé qu'on a adopté un
plan massif pour être en capacité de
produire des millions de véhicules
électriques d'ici à la fin du
quinquennat que nous avons 2 giga
Factory de batterie électrique qui ont
ouvert dans le nord de la France et ça
tout le monde peut le voir et le
constater nous avons retenu en revanche
des économies supplémentaires sur la
question de la formation et c'était une
des orientation qui était portée par le
Sénat monsieur ça vaut le délit on peut
pas dire que parce qu'on fait des
économies sur France compétences via le
compte personnel de formation on à bas
comme vous l'avez dit je crois la
formation professionnelle dans notre
pays moi je rappelle quand même que le
budget du ministère de l'Emploi et de la
Formation Professionnelle augmente de 6
milliards 700 millions d'euros donc
qu'est-ce que ce serait si véritablement
on s'attaquait fortement à la formation
professionnelle c'est pas vrai les
crédits augmentent massivement mais on
doit faire des économistes structurelles
et notamment sur France compétences ça
nous anime régulièrement dans les
discussions et les débats que nous avons
donc je crois qu'avec ce texte nous
sommes parvenus à trouver une solution à
une équation qui est évidemment
difficile tenir nos comptes et notre
objectif de déficit à 5% tout en
accompagnant les Français les
entreprises et les collectivités locales
pour faire face aux chocs de l'inflation
et de la hausse des prix de l'énergie et
garder des moyens pour investir pour
l'avenir pour le réarmement de service
public et la transition écologique je
crois profondément que nous y arrivons
avec le budget tel qu'il est issu de
l'Assemblée nationale nous aurions pu en
débattre davantage dans les jours qui
viennent mais était important pour moi
de le rappeler
merci Monsieur Louise j'en déduis que
vous ne donnez pas un avis de sagesse
sur la motion mais plutôt un avis
négatif
alors j'ai deux demandes d'explication
de votre d'abord monsieur Gueriot
merci monsieur le Président
j'ai beaucoup entendu les uns les autres
avec force de conviction développer le
la frustration qui est la leur mes chers
collègues concernant des amendements qui
n'ont pas pu être tenus je partage cette
frustration et enfin sur certains
amendements qui étaient votés à
l'unanimité
constater que finalement le débat
pourrait se poursuivre eu égard en
mettant le focus justement sur ces sur
ces aspects qui méritent peut-être
d'être encore davantage exprimé
davantage défendu peut pareil être
essentiel et c'est pour ça je moi ce qui
m'étonne enfin
et je partage pas cette notion qui est
dans la motion qui est de dire que
probablement si nous poursivions cette
discussion cela ne conduirait
vraisemblablement à ne pas faire évoluer
le texte j'en suis pas certain j'en suis
pas certain et c'est pour ça que je
m'interroge entre ce qui peut
exprimer finalement cette frustration de
ne pas pouvoir être pleinement tendu et
finalement de se priver de pouvoir
l'être je voudrais quand même rappeler
qu'après la guerre 40 après la Seconde
Guerre mondiale nous avons une période
qu'on appelait le Conseil de la
République qui a duré 12 ans et pendant
cette période là et bien la haute
assemblée était totalement privée de son
pouvoir législatif il a fallu attendre
1954 pour que les choses reviennent et
cela nous l'avons dû à deux sénateurs
qui étaient Gaston Monnerville et puis
Michel Debré qui se sont battus pas à
pas pas pour qu'on retrouve cette
vocation législative qui est la nôtre
aujourd'hui j'ai le sentiment que l'on
fait à marche arrière c'est à dire qu'on
va se priver de pouvoir de l'expression
libre qui est la nôtre avec
effectivement peut-être à la fin un
résultat qui sera pas à la hauteur de ce
que nous pouvons espérer mais Dieu peut
y avoir un résultat et c'est cela ce à
quoi nous devons attendre du Parlement
je regrette vraiment que nous revenions
encore une fois sur une seconde lecture
qui ne pourra pas se faire alors que
c'est un droit législatif que nous avons
acquis avec parfois des difficultés
majeures et c'est une dignité qui est la
nôtre de pouvoir donc voilà la raison
pour laquelle le groupe Les Indépendants
c'est Noël mais tout de même alors la
parole est au président de La Haye merci
monsieur le Président mais j'avais
demandé la parole pour intervenir contre
parce que le rapporteur général est
intervenu pour et on a le droit
d'intervenir contre et normalement on a
10 minutes et non pas deux minutes donc
je sais pas ce que vous m'accordez pour
Noël je sais pas ce que vous m'accordez
pour Noël monsieur le Président c'est
deux ou 10
quand même normalement c'est contre ces
deux quand même alors allez-y je vais
essayer de mentir à deux mais moi je
voulais dire que au sein du groupe de
l'Union centriste nous étions quelques
collègues qui pensent que ça serait bien
que on puisse continuer à discuter même
si monsieur le ministre nous écoute pas
nous écoute mais nous n'entend pas
vraiment mais on aurait aimé qui est
beaucoup plus de nos propositions qui
soient retenues et pour cela on aurait
aimé avoir essayé de faire un peu plus
preuve de conviction peut-être faut-il
plus de temps pour que le gouvernement
accepte de prendre en compte un certain
nombre de propositions du Sénat et plus
intéressante que ce qui a été pris en
compte jusqu'à présent alors moi je
m'inscris quand même en faux monsieur le
ministre avec quand vous dites les
comptes sont tenus ils sont absolument
pas tenus à 165 milliards de déficits
avec 270 milliards de dettes nouvelles
cette année on peut pas considérer que
cette tenue moi je regrette vous auriez
baissé de 20 milliards le déficit
j'aurais pu vous dire vous êtes dans la
bonne direction oui mais là on est pas
dans la bonne direction du tout on reste
à un niveau très élevé alors qu'on est
plus dans années exceptionnelle on a
connu des années exceptionnelles de
crise sanitaire effectivement on a dû
aider peut-être de façon trop large à
mon avis mais enfin bon
une fois qu'on est sorti de cette
période là on devrait revenir à des
niveaux antérieurs qui étaient déjà
élevés de déficit qui était autour de
100 milliards et là on est à 165
milliards donc honnêtement c'est pas
tenu alors on a fait beaucoup de
propositions on est vraiment déçu de ne
pas avoir été entendu sur ses
propositions et honnêtement je pense
qu'il faudra quand même réfléchir pour
l'avenir à se dire on y va on va sur une
deuxième lecture et on sélectionne un
certain nombre de sujets limités parce
qu'on peut pas tout embrasser mais dans
une deuxième lecture mais quelques
sujets sur lesquels on souhaite attirer
particulièrement l'attention du
gouvernement et aussi des médias à
travers à travers ses lectures voilà
monsieur le Président je vais rester
dans mon temps de parole que vous m'avez
un petit peu écourté mais je vous en
remercie je vous souhaite un Joyeux Noël
bon tiens allez en attendant le joyeux
Noël c'est Monsieur Breuillet qui va
prendre son temps
enfin son temps 2 minutes merci monsieur
le Président c'est toujours difficile de
se quitter après des moments si agréable
et comme vous monsieur le ministre
j'aime le débat et parfois jusqu'à la
nuit et parfois en ayant l'impression
que continuer à débattre ne permet pas
de convaincre et ne change pas une
position du gouvernement qui de toute
façon reste sourde aux amendements même
lorsqu'elles viennent parfois de gens
assez proches de lui-même pour notre
part nous ne voterons pas cette question
préalable parce que dans ces attendus il
y a beaucoup attendus qui que nous ne
partageons pas et puis je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure dans ma DG nous nous sentons
un peu protagonistes d'une comédie
burlesque sur l'inutilité parlementaire
dont au fond le dernier acte va se tenir
avec le vote de cette notion préalable
et je conclurai puisqu'on est dans le
théâtre avec une citation de Marcel
Pagnol la pièce était si mauvaise que
les acteurs eux vous partez avant la fin
merci Monsieur Savoldelli
oui merci monsieur le Président
monsieurmiste d'abord faut pas se mentir
il y a des délais constitutionnels c'est
20 jours de débat au Sénat ça nous
impose et là j'utilise la formule le
quoi qu'il en coûte d'arrêter les
travaux vendredi soir donc il faut une
réforme il faut une réforme
je ferme cette question là la deuxième
chose c'est que vous demandez une
cohérence que le ministre mais pas pas
mon groupe nous avions posé la question
préalable parce que nous savions déjà
que vous aviez vous un préalable c'était
le 49-3
et sur le sérieux de nos travaux
franchement et sans être plus polémique
qu'il le faut mais vous croyez que la
biodiversité c'est une affaire de l'auto
voyez que c'est une affaire de l'auto le
loto que vous avez fait pendant toute la
démarche du PLF et sur d'autres
questions pellefss assurant chômage etc
vous avez tiré 10 fois le même numéro
49,3 on peut pas au loto le faire et le
Parlement c'est pas une loterie par le
c'est pas la loterie parlementaire ici
on joue pas avec ça troisièmement c'est
que je voulais vous dire pour qu'on va
s'abstenir sur la motion parce que c'est
quand même pas nous les communistes avec
d'autres à gauche qui allons arbitrer
l'hégémonie des droites sur les droites
parce que c'est ça votre affaire au-delà
des aspects budgétaires et fiscal c'est
de savoir qui a l'hégémonie des valeurs
de droite des idéologies du libéralisme
donc on vous laisse en découdre mais ne
comptez pas sur nous pour participer à
ce jeu de dupe merci
merci la parole est au président canner
merci monsieur le Président
mon groupe peut donc va voter cette
motion de procédure
non pas parce que nous serions devenus
des amis absolus de la droite c'est
notoriale mais parce que on veut
s'associer à cette fin de journée de
dupe j'en ai de dupes qui a commencé au
début de ce cet examen du budget
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
vous êtes dans une tenaille qui est
simple c'est que vous développez un
déficit budgétaire qui est énorme
et vous ne donnez pas les moyens de
pouvoir le combler nous nous avons fait
les propositions
utilisez les super dividendes et nous
étions d'ailleurs
accompagnés par d'autres la matière à
utiliser les super profits pour refaire
rentrer des recettes
en échange vous diminuez les recettes de
l'État vous creusez le déficit par vous
même avec des choix liés à un dogme qui
était présenté par Monsieur olive Véran
dans l'ordre d'une émission de radio il
y a quelques semaines nous avons un
dogme avait-il dit celui du moins
d'impôts
l'impôt n'est pas une injure c'est pas
un gros mot monsieur le ministre quand
il est bien utilisé quand il permet de
répartir correctement la richesse
produite par les Français mais quand
vous supprimez la TH quand vous
supprimez la CVE même en deux ans quand
vous supprimez la redevance TV et que
vous confort et que vous devez bien sûr
compenser cette baisse de recettes et
bien c'est 35 milliards de moins dans
les caisses de l'État une fois cela dit
et bien vous n'arrivez pas à vous en
sortir et c'est toujours les mêmes qui
payent aujourd'hui et nous le verrons
aussi sur le débat prochain sur les
retraites j'étais avec Madame borne ce
matin avec les ministres iriester et
Olivier des sautes et nous avons compris
la volonté qui est la vôtre gagner 10
milliards d'euros 10 milliards d'euros
sur 30 334 milliards d'euros c'est une
PKI à la hauteur du déficit de l'État et
bien aujourd'hui nous défendons au
travers y compris de ce vote celles et
ceux qui ont besoin d'un état solidaire
ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
merci
avant de donner la parole au président
ok je vous rappelle que ensuite ce sera
un scrutin public sur la motion merci de
vous y préparer monsieur le Président
Ruquier merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur chers collègue mais notre
groupe par principe votre contre la
question préalable nous en comprenons la
finalité on en attend le résultat mais
donc nous votre rencontre alors il a été
fait appel à la durée d'analyses et du
budget sous la Quatrième République
et on va de l'instabilité ministérielle
souvent les budgets n'étaient pas votés
à temps et ce que faisait les huissiers
les huissiers arrêtaient les pendules à
minuit jusqu'à ce que on trouve dans les
jours suivants une solution dont je
crois que nous n'aurons pas arrêté les
pendules et nous porterons d'ici avec un
budget rôti
merci monsieur le Président plus
personne ne demande d'explication de
vote très bien nous allons donc en
application de l'article 59 du règlement
votez sur cette notion par un scrutin
public ordinaire
le scrutin est ouvert
Richard vous voulez bien confirmer votre
vote
cher vous votez pour la motion
oui oui non mais moi
je veux pas d'incident pour rien mais
je voyais le ministre le ministre qui
commençait à blanchir devant vous
Monsieur je voudrais pas une défaillance
le dernier jour de séance non non mais
pas du tout là là vous savez moi plus
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
est clos
exprimé 314 pour la motion
260 contre 54 la motion est adoptée
la parole est très rapide à Madame
Sylvie vermeiller
merci monsieur le Président cher
collègue je souhaite apporter une
notifications de votre concernant le
scrutin numéro 29 séances du 4 novembre
2022 portant sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi relatif à l'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelable lors
de ce scrutin Madame Nathalie Goulet
souhaitait voter contre je vous remercie
donner de votre mise au point mes chers
collègues après avoir remercié monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur
général et monsieur le président de la
commission des Finances ainsi que toutes
celles et tous ceux qui sont la ce matin
je vais lever la séance prochaine séance
mardi 10 janvier à 14h30 pour le débat
sur la gestion de l'eau dans une
perspective économique et écologique la
séance est levée